las vegas real estate market is so hot
that not even a fixer-upper can save you
money
this is according to porch.com's latest
data
they looked at current real estate
listings in 500 markets across the us to
determine
where you might save the most buying a
fixer-upper home and las vegas is not
one of them in fact
we rank number five for cities where
fixer-uppers are discounted the least
right now
behind boston mesa arizona riverside
california
and phoenix the best places for
fixer-uppers omaha nebraska
discounted a whopping 62 percent for
comparison
the average fixer upper discount
nationally is 25 percent
the average discount in las vegas is 3
percent
because the national real estate market
is at an all-time high
it seems to be trickling down to these
homes that historically
have been heavily discounted and
have been reserved maybe for people who
couldn't enter the housing market
otherwise or really handy people or even
investors
but now it seems like they're almost
competing at the same price as a move-in
ready home which is kind of
mind-boggling to me
so fixer-upper is defined as a home that
can be lived in but needs some form of
tlc or updating that would allow for it
to be sold at a discounted price
as we mentioned this is a seller's
market people trying to get rid of these
fixer-uppers
are asking for top dollar even though
the home may not be
in the best shape if you're betting the
over on me saying fixer upper
cash your ticket